so you do have to realize at a certain
point no matter how
woke you want to seem no matter how
you're you're the enemy
you will become the enemy because
violence doesn't have a rationale
you know the point of torture jane mayer
said it when we were torturing people
remember that
remember that eight years ago uh
jane mayer she was either quoting
somebody or she said this she might have
been quoting someone
she goes the point of torture is always
torture
okay and that's really the point of
violence is violence like it has its own
rationale and it spreads and it's not
logical
and what happens is you basically
just you know you become a an animal
you beca and and the type of
state-sanctioned violence that we see is
very organized but it's no less
animalistic
it's you know no less brutal so when
you're just going out there and you're
hurting
innocent people and you are destroying
small businesses some of them owned by
minorities and you're just
you know going out there and
using violence it will lead to more
violence and then we're just again we're
we're living in
and and to me i don't understand why so
many people are
fetishizing that idea the idea of just a
con and i think it's because they don't
know anything about violence and they're
like live in a video game
and they don't have any respect for it
and they think they can direct it's like
a force they think they can direct
they think well if we unleash this
violence we can direct it to the means
that we find
appropriate we think that this violence
can be used
to and it's like but that's not the way
it works that's not the way it works
it's
i mean look at any of these videos of of
of these these white people like
cheering on the riots and then bricks
come through their windows they're like
we're on your side
no we're we're good we're the good ones
and it's like no no no you you can't put
the genie back in the bottle it's out
chaos is chaos and if you want to live
in that world and a lot of the people
that are like abolish
the police will not do well in a mad max
scenario
because they're immunocompromised and
they're 97 pounds
okay where are you gonna get your green
hair dye
without a civil society okay
so i don't think this ends again with
a fat woman with green hair is the
president antifa takes over wouldn't
that be funny yeah
antifa takes over how hilarious would
that be
like somehow they like maybe
everything's a lie and our military
is does suck yeah like they can't do
anything we just hear how great they are
but let's say they just
aren't that great obviously we know that
they'll just use weaponry from the skies
but let's say none of that works and
somehow antifa succeeds because the
conservatives are pretending antifa is
like
it can antifa will do you want them
running the country it would just be
hilarious
if like you know the country was now
being run by just gangly
you know mainly white pale malnourished
vitamin d deficient like
guys that didn't get the montreal comedy
festival
like like failed comics and
slam poets with purple hair
are now running the country that would
be great
the fox news has to come back on the air
and be like
in a stunning
[Laughter]
in a really surprising development
antifa
has defeated what was the united states
military uh they are now
running the country antifa
has fired the military and they are now
replacing it with a security force of
mainly theater kids who grew and
bittered at the lack of opportunity in
the entertainment business
and became volatile and radical
whilst living with roommates in their
late thirties
they will now be the security force of
the country
angry failed theater kids
are now running around i'm gonna be
amazing
like instead of the blue angels instead
of the flyover over the super bowl
just you just like a bunch of antifa
just runs through and everyone like
everything the crowd's like i guess
i guess they're they're the run they're
running it now
okay well all right usa just a bunch of
like malnourished kids
usa just black backpacks on yeah
people are like you you can take your
masks off you run everything now
they're like we like the masks they have
acne
like we have adult acne so we're not
going to take off the mask you know
but that that's the way people talk
about antifa like it's like it's like
they're they're like they're on their
way to
you know they're gonna defeat uh the the
corporate state it doesn't
and i don't agree with anything antifa
does by the way for the most part i
think some of what they say is decent
and i don't really care like you know
none of it see here's the thing it's
like you could find an example of
somebody that anthony was like throwing
an egg at who you hate
right i [ __ ] that guy they threw an
egg at him
but we live in a country where people
should be able to say what the [ __ ] they
want
so no you can't use violence to stop
people from talking
you can't when the new york times
publishes it not bad
by the way the same people that think
that they can live in a world without
police cannot handle when the new york
times publishes an op-ed from a senator
who says we've got to bring the military
in so instead of debating that
they go you know this is we the new york
times should be shut down
there should be a coup everyone should
be fired i can't believe they'd print
that opinion
but you're gonna you're gonna somehow
how are you so
how are you gonna live in a world
without any police you can't handle an
article
can't handle jordan peterson and yet
somehow you think you're gonna be able
to live in a world
without any order at all just chaos and
anarchy that's a fetish you know anarchy
is a fetish of of losers really it's
people that are convinced that
they will somehow either be powerful or
align themselves with the powerful
people once society's fallen
even though they've been unable to do
that thus far
they've been unable to do that thus far
but they think that
somehow if there are no police that rich
people won't just go higher black water
military types
to patrol wealthy areas and we'll have
more problems
probably less accountability you know
they just
they just somehow think that and or some
of them are just
nihilus to the point where they go who
cares burn it down i mean
oscar the cat many of you know
is someone who is a nihilist i mean
oscar
first of all and this is very suspect
and strange two days ago oscar joined
the national guard
he has never expressed interest in
joining the military before
he joined the national guard okay
okay this is incredibly disappointing
okay but a day before that he was
he was handing out bricks to protesters
so he just wants to watch it burn
there's a lot of people out there that
just want to watch it burn
and this is what i mean listen so this
is where we are
this is where we are on uh what day is
it today thursday
it's thursday this is coming forth yes
thursday june 4th it's coming out sunday
super proud of everyone from long island
proud you handled it
you guys really killed it you knocked it
out of the park
you brought your kids out to see what
you're all about yelling at
people that haven't that want to
peacefully protest
i like that that's good good for you
long island just keep
being long island you know and every
year it gets a little worse
a little less affordable more of them
get pushed out
every year more and more people start
you know shooting up opioid crisis gets
worse every year
you know um because so much of what that
community is based on
is fear and hatred
which turns out is not exactly the best
way
it's not the best organizing principle
of society
utter illogical fear
and hatred that's what long island is
everybody's climbing in your window
ms-13 is trying to kill you everybody's
trying to kill you
everybody on the road is trying to cut
you off to try to get somewhere faster
than you
everybody's trying to take your money
trying to take that house you inherited
fear and hatred
as soon as you're fear you're like well
i gotta i gotta hate someone
so i just like that they were being
you know exactly who they are
perfect and the the cops got to pretend
that they're like neutral on long island
the cops can be like hey you know this
i know jimmy i know just shoot him
hey you got a gun tommy just shoot him
in the head
jimmy they're high school students who
cares
you know what high school students can
do if they want put a
bullet in the back of her head
that's antenna
they're trying to take over the delis
what's gonna happen when antifa controls
the delis
then what you're going to eat vegan [ __ ]
you're going to get a bacon egg and
cheese and there's going to be some
transgender
making you eat vegan no thank you i will
eat processed food
and i will die on my couch watching
tucker carlson